Traductor: Denise RQ
Revisor: Marta Palacio
En 1796, Thomas Jefferson recibió una
caja de huesos que no pudo identificar.
Una garra larga y afilada
le recordó a un león
pero los huesos del brazo
sugerían un animal más grande,
uno de unos tres metros de largo.
Creyendo que podía ser una especie enorme
y desconocida de león de América del Norte
Jefferson advirtió a los exploradores
Lewis y Clark que tuvieran cuidado
con este misterioso depredador.
Pero la caja de huesos de Jefferson
no provenía de un león.
Venía de un perezoso
gigante ahora extinto.
Los perezosos prehistóricos
aparecieron por primera vez
hace unos 35 millones de años.
Decenas de esta especie vivieron en
América de Norte, Central y del Sur
junto a otras criaturas antiguas
como mastodontes y armadillos gigantes.
Algunos perezosos de tierra, como el
megaloníquido, eran de tamaño gato,
pero muchos eran enormes.
El perezoso de Jefferson, Megalonyx,
pesaba cerca de una tonelada
y era pequeño en comparación
con el Megatherium,
que podía alcanzar las seis toneladas,
como un elefante.
Deambulaban por bosques y sabanas
usando sus fuertes brazos
y afiladas garras
para arrancar raíces
y trepar a los árboles,
alimentándose de hierba, hojas,
y aguacates prehistóricos.
De hecho, podríamos no tener aguacates
de no ser por los perezosos gigantes.
Los animales más pequeños no podían
tragar la gran semilla del aguacate,
pero los perezosos sí,
y así se expandieron
los árboles de aguacate.
Los perezosos terrestres
prosperaron por millones de años,
pero hace 10 000 años,
comenzaron a desaparecer
junto con los otros mamíferos
gigantes del hemisferio occidental.
Los investigadores creen que los
perezosos podrían haber sido expulsados
por una edad de hielo que se avecinaba
o competencia con otras especies,
quizá seres humanos,
quienes llegaron a la región
cuando la mayoría de los
perezosos se extinguieron.
Algunos de los perezosos más pequeños
sobrevivieron y emigraron
a las copas de los árboles.
Hoy en día quedan seis especies
que viven en las copas de los árboles
de las selvas tropicales
de América Central y del Sur.
Vivir en los árboles es una buena manera
de evitar a los depredadores,
y hay muchas hojas para comer.
Pero esta dieta tiene sus inconvenientes.
Los animales extraen energía
de los alimentos y usan esa energía
para moverse, mantener
su temperatura corporal,
mantener sus órganos funcionando,
y todas las demás funciones
necesarias para la supervivencia.
Pero las hojas no contienen mucha energía,
y la que tienen es difícil de extraer.
La mayoría de los herbívoros
complementan su dieta a base de hojas
con alimentos que aportan más
energía, como frutas y semillas.
Pero los perezosos, especialmente
los perezosos de tres dedos,
dependen de las hojas casi exclusivamente.
Han desarrollado estrategias optimizadas
para hacer frente a esa dieta restringida.
Primero, extraen tanta energía
de su alimento como sea posible.
Los perezosos tienen un estómago de varias
cámaras que ocupa un tercio de su cuerpo
y dependiendo de la especie,
pueden pasar de cinco a siete días,
o incluso semanas, digiriendo una comida.
La otra pieza del rompecabezas
es usar la menor energía posible.
Una forma en que los perezosos hacen esto,
por supuesto, es no moviéndose mucho.
Pasan la mayor parte de su tiempo
comiendo, descansando o durmiendo.
Descienden de las copas
una sola vez a la semana
para hacer sus necesidades.
Cuando los perezosos se
mueven, no son muy rápidos.
Un perezoso necesitaría unos cinco minutos
para cruzar una calle de un barrio normal.
Este enfoque sin prisas sobre la vida
significa que los perezosos
no necesitan mucho músculo.
De hecho, tienen un 30 % menos de masa
muscular que otros animales de su tamaño.
Los perezosos también usan menos
energía para mantenerse calientes
porque su temperatura corporal
puede fluctuar alrededor de 5 °C,
menos que un reptil de sangre fría,
pero más que la mayoría de los mamíferos.
Estas adaptaciones físicas y de conducta
reducen el gasto de energía del perezoso,
o tasa metabólica.
Los perezosos de tres dedos tienen el
metabolismo más lento entre los mamíferos.
El panda gigante es el segundo más lento,
y los perezosos de dos dedos
vienen en tercer lugar.
Moverse lentamente ha permitido
que los perezosos prosperen
en su hábitat de la copa de los árboles.
Pero también los propios perezosos son
un gran hábitat para otros organismos,
incluyendo algas, que proporcionan
un poco de camuflaje adicional,
y tal vez incluso un aperitivo.
Puede que los perezosos
ya no sean gigantes,
pero eso no los hace menos admirables.